All right.
Let's
to get to the phones at six one seven, eight
three zero 47 50 lots of people with much
to say today.
Let's start with our color from the four oh
eight area code.
Who's calling today from four oh eight.
Hi David.
Yeah, that's you.
I David, this is fluke.
I'm a staunch Democrat from California.
Great.
I'm going into the going into the 2020 election.
I have a concerned, I've been debating with
my friends and I just wanted to know your
thoughts on it.
Sure.
What was the concern?
Um, you know, you know, I have some coworker
who are, uh, you know, Trump supporters and
uh, I'm concerned about both the enthusiasm,
energy, and voter turnout of democratic loader.
Um, I know that Hillary, she had the same
democratic voter.
I mean, Democratic voters that Barack Obama
did is just not enough.
It was less.
And speaking from personal experience, I have
family members and friends who, um, you know,
they're not regular voters, but they did come
out to vote for President Obama both times
when it came to Hillary.
They just weren't excited by her.
Some of them thought that she was gonna win
any way.
Uh, some of them, you know, they just weren't
as excited.
So some of them didn't come out to vote for
her.
And I'm actually, I'm concerned that, um,
we'll want a democratic candidate that could,
you know, energize the voters.
Um, I'm not seeing that right now in the field.
So I'm just wanting about your thoughts.
Well, I think the issue is bigger than the
field right now.
I mean, I just, I don't know that right now
we can say, listen in all of the head to head,
hypothetical matchups basically every Democrat
who has a shot at winning the nomination is
doing well against Trump at the national level.
But remember, Hillary had more than enough
votes to defeat Trump at the national level.
In the popular vote.
The problem was because of 77,000 votes or
72,000 votes in three states, she lost the
electoral college, which of course is what
matters.
I mean, we've got an electoral college election.
I'm not pretending like that doesn't matter.
So I think that what, you know, every year
we always hear similar storylines.
Whoever can get out the vote is going to win.
This year, the millennials and the young people,
people who were old enough to vote last time,
they're really gonna come out for x or y candidate.
And that will be the difference maker.
And in the end it's like the trends are always
the same, which is that the electoral college
favors Republicans over Democrats at a systemic
level that young people don't end up really
voting that much.
And the most reliable voters are the older
folks who have been voting for a really long
time.
So I share with you the skepticism about voter
turnout, but for me, it's not so much connected
to any particular candidate.
It's a much more general thing.
I just think a lot of the enthusiasm that
started when Donald Trump was elected and
inaugurated has faded partially because people
have become numb to the insanity, partially
because of what's called scandal fatigue and
partially because of normalization.
So I share your concerns, but for me it's
much more overarching than about will comma
Harris versus Bernie versus Biden get people
to come out and vote.
Um, I know right now the, a lot of the candidates,
Democratic candidates are talking about policy
and such and um, that's sort of on an intellectual
level.
I know that a lot of voters and a lot of people,
they vote it's kind of a popularity contest.
They both based upon their feelings how they
feel about certain candidates.
Uh, you know, some of the Trump supporter,
they said that, you know, they don't care
about lies.
I don't care about all the scandals.
What's important is the way the Trump made
his vote or feel Trump made his voters feel
that they are on winning team.
They're on team America trying to make America
great again against these enemies or these
opponents that are like fake news, immigrants,
et cetera.
You know, and I wonder about, you know, Barack
Obama, he made people would, they don't really
remember all his policies or what he says,
but he made people feel hopeful for change.
He made them feel cool.
Um, and that's why they were excited.
You know, even my family members who don't
normally vote, they came down because President
Obama, uh, Barack Obama, he made him feel
great.
So right now I'm worried that we were talking
so much about intellectual things, you know,
about policies and such.
I mean, I'm wondering if the candidate knows
to focus on how to make voter feel, you know,
positive and good and to come out and vote
super important.
I take issue with the idea that talking about
policy is like this over intellectualizing
esoterics thing.
I think it is important, but I think the key
is to mix the two things you're saying.
I think candidates should be able to talk
about policy in a way that will directly relate
and connect emotionally to the voter in a
way that is important to them.
A very important points.
I really appreciate the call and I hope to
hear from you again and I share the concern
about voter enthusiasm.
No question about it